hallo mein name ist willkommen liebe
freunde wir spielen heute den longmodus
see me later
das heißt wir männer
rasen neue karriere erstellen keine
ahnung was ein rasenmäher karriere sein
soll aber okay wir spielen mit
anleitungen oder wir was springen sie
wir brauchen keine
perfekte das ist schon genauso aus wie
ich unser firmenname ist die rasen racer
alteration doppel er
als logo würde ich sagen nehmen wir
einfach eine kettensäge
spielt aber arbeit um
spielername
also wenn ihr kein abonnent aufnehmen
kann dann weiß ich auch nicht jetzt kann
man auch noch ein rasenmäher aussuchen
es gibt einmal diesen gelben hier der
hat 99 ps und fährt fünf meilen pro
stunde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den braucht man who dann haben wir aber
nur noch
wenig geld übrig wir müssen richtig
kalkulieren neben den hier einfach mal
das ist diese auf
wo ich will einfach
rasenmähen zwei tage später los gehts
meine lieben freunde der rasen mähen
simulator er startet das ist unser ziel
für heute einen vorgarten im old nugg.ad
wir haben eine schnitthöhe von 5 cm eine
terra prüfung von vier minuten und eine
recom endet teil von
626 sind tiere die an die rechnung ohne
die rasend gemacht
[Musik]
ja gut ich klicke jetzt einfach mal auf
enter losgeht wir können hier rumlaufen
wir haben
keinen körper
dmb
das hier so glaube ich ein kalender
erstellen sehr sie zumindest einem
kalender ähnlich wir haben hier einen
klienten stehen die haben hier so ein
paar gesagt entstehen da hängt
fahrrad an der decke
können wir nicht irgendwie den karrieren
hier irgendwie
ihr könnt mir nicht nehmen das war
natürlich gelesen wir damit einfach über
den rasen darüber hätten fahren können
hier fordern wir doch einen oldtimer ich
denke mal dass sollen alter aston martin
sein oder vielleicht auch in austin
healey kann man vielleicht auch an denen
das gericht ob das heute
heißt es nicht an jaguar von der seite
sieht auf dem posten wie die von vorne
und hinten von vorne mit aston martin
und von hinten jaguar egal wir können ja
hinten auf jeden fall laufen immer noch
mülltonnen perfekt sandys auch am start
so kleiner
wir noch eine gießkanne die auf dem
boden liegt da können wir auch
drüber laufen
sehr gut rein gehen können wir hier
leider nicht wir können mit nichts hier
so richtig interagieren hier vorne
liegen nur noch tennisbälle was ist das
das würstchen hier vorne haben wir einen
grill damit können wir aber glaube ich
auch nichts machen da steht wo eine
falle drauf wie eine kleine sitzecke das
ist echt schwierig ja alles ist einfach
so england in der folge sind tiere
irgendwie sieht der hase ein bisschen
verkohlt aus dann können wir auf jeden
fall noch hier vorne rum laufen da haben
wir noch ein kleines gartenhäuschen ist
auch schönes wetter in hessen richtig
schöner tag zum rasenmähen sie haben auf
jeden fall ein gartenhäuschen damit kann
ich auch nicht interagieren die sache
benötige ich auch erstmal nicht denke
ich und hier müssen wir definitiv den
rasen mähen also dass auf jeden fall hin
kriegen meine lieben freunde wird
warum läuft denn unsere zeit schonen
teilte y gedrückt und den motor zu
starten laut genau hin
damit kriegt sie lara score zu mit y
aktivist die messe scheint es ja ab
guckt euch das an die sauber ich das
milieu
überlasse es den motor drosselt ihnen
vor beendigung
strafe du hast grasschnitt
achtung du benutzt die falsche schnitt
5,7 cm eingestellt dementsprechend jetzt
drehzahl aktivieren so wir fahren los
und aktivieren die mehr sound jetzt geht
es hier nämlich los jetzt hier
wirklichkeit und jetzt müssen wir gleich
allerdings so ein bisschen schauen dass
wir du hast grasschnitt zurückgelassen
was für grasschnitt junge ist mir
scheißegal wenn ihr weiter rummeckern
mehr ich da ja noch den cayenne von
denen kaputt aber hier vorne lang dann
können wir jetzt hier die linkskurve
reingehen und natürlich schon mal rein
spalt weiter ich liebe rasen binde ich
hatte auch früher so einen kleinen
aufsitzrasenmäher da kann ich jedem foto
von einblenden ich war stolz wie saure
vor ihr macht so auf einem sonntagmorgen
und es ist so ein schöner frühlingstag
st 15 grad die sonne scheinen und die
kommt raus und der rasen ist ein
bisschen gewachsen und dann setzt ihr
euch auf euren aufsitzrasenmäher ein
bisschen mucke autoren oder ein podcast
besten dick und doof
spotify gerne anhören und dann geht so
richtig einer weggeweht einfach mal das
ganze wird hier wieder schön gemacht ich
bin allerdings ganz ehrlich hier mit
diesem
raus hier finde ich so ein bisschen
blöd
ich finde dass links irgendwie schöner
als das rechts
[Musik]
ich bin soll talent ich habe mich
geeignete eingeblendet habt ihr ja
wahrscheinlich gesehen wie ich hier
alles mögliche weg gewählt habt ihr
werdet schon oben rechts ich bin beim
fortschritt fast schon bei 80 prozent
also vier fünftel beziehungsweise 80
prozent habe ich halt schon durch und es
macht wirklich laune man hat richtig
bock das hier so alles perfekt zu machen
nicht weiter sind auch so ein paar
stückchen du hast den boden beschädigt
und die eine strafe eingekauft als
draufgänger wir sind immerhin auf ein
paar kleine stückchen die muss ich
natürlich noch weggehen aber das macht
schon spaß um mich ja das wirklich an
richtiges rasen mähen ich weiß noch beim
rasenmähen ich hatte früher einmal eine
kleine anekdote aus meinem extrem lang
bei dem leben hier mal wieder ich habe
früher mal rasen gemäht und habe mir
generell bei uns im
haushalt immer so ein bisschen geld dazu
verdienen wenn ich mal so rasen gemäht
ab oder laub aufgesammelt oder keine
ahnung was gemacht habe und dankte
spielzeug von meiner schwester auf dem
boden irgendwie noch im garten im sommer
und ich hab da bin ich einfach drüber
gefahren das war so einen rasenmäher dem
man sowieso ziehen oder nie in der sonne
da musst du vorher schieben auf einmal
war da ebenso eine playmobil figur oder
barbie oder sofern wir das wetter war
weg gemäht
die denkt bis heute dass die
irgendwo auf dem capo fliegt aber die
habe ich hier kaputt gemäht und
weggeschmissen
sarah ich hoffe du wirst dieses video
hier niemals sehen
wer seid ihr scheiß egal ich habe alles
weg gemäht was sich irgendwie konnte
hier ist nichts mehr übrig ich bin
trotzdem erst 98,4 prozent falls aber
volle kanone gegenüber
wird der garten zu trinken ist ein
schönes häuschen lieben freunde ist auch
eine schöne meter rasen ich zeige ihnen
noch mal ganz kurz hier zum ende ich
weiß nicht was ich jetzt machen muss
klar hier sind noch so kleinigkeiten die
man auf jeden fall besser hätte machen
können aber ich finde ich hab das schon
ganz gut gemacht und 98,4 prozent des
wegen beleidigung meiner rasenmäher
skills und vor allem an die firma rasen
racer von da ich will das jetzt gern
beenden ich weiß nicht wie das
funktioniert möchte sagte ein
ford-sprecher du willst aber jeglichen
auftritt von die
perfekte gar
nichts dazu gewonnen
ich dachte ich habs jetzt beendet aber
ich habe es einfach nur abgebrochen
wenn euch das heutige video von daher an
der stelle gefallen hat dann einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und kriegt selbst
wahrscheinlich auf die glocke wenn der
neue videos nicht verpassen wollt es
geht in einigen tagen weiter mit den
letzten episoden minecraft mit luca also
abonniert auf jeden fall einen kanal und
tragt euch für den kalender einem 10 10
kommt neues merchandise in den luca bino
shop.de ich hoffe ihr freut euch wir
sehen uns die tage wieder
[Musik]